l'actualité de ce 9 juillet c'est donc
avec Alice Gastine bonsoir Alice et on
débute avec l'Open de golf qui s'est
achevé dimanche soir oui l'stom Open de
France qui a réuni plus de 15000
spectateurs un petit peu comme l'année
dernière au Golf National de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline et qui a
consacré l'Allemand Marcel Zim donc il a
devancé d'un coup l'italien Francesco
Molinari et de deux couroups Raphaël
Jacquemain le français he qui avait
suscité l'engouement du public c'est la
deuxième victoire de Mar zim sur le
circuit européen après son succès au D
Hill Championship en 2004 je apppplaudir
Marcel
Allemagne la 96e édition de l'Open de
golf s'est refermée dimanche sur la
victoire de l'Allemand Marcel SIM une
victoire sur le fil il devance d'un coup
seulement l'italien Francesco Molinari
un coup à 525000 € c'est la somme
touchée par le vainqueur cette année
Marcel SIM est 14e ou 15e à la Monnay
liste
le joueur Erin Stenson est 13e donc non
il y a pas de surprise il y a un peu de
déception avec Raphaël qui a été pendant
quelques trous en
tête le nouveau numéro 1 français
Raphaël Jacquelin termine sur la
dernière marche du podium avec seulement
de points de retard le public était venu
nombreux aux abord du parcours de
l'Albatros pour le soutenir vous suivez
quel joueur en particulier aujourd'hui
Jacquin pourquoi bah parce qu'on
l'aime je suis Jacquelin pourquoi lui
bah parce que d'abord c'est un très bon
joueur et qu'il est très sympathique
voilà et qu'il y a une un enthousiasme
derrière lui qui est porteur l'Open
cette année n'aura pas été épargné par
les mauvaises conditions météo malgré
tout le bilan reste positif aujourd'hui
on doit avoir entre 10 et 12000
spectateurs c'est moins bien que les les
14 ou 16000 qu'on a eu l'année dernière
mais il faut rappeler que l'année
dernière on avait un Français qui était
en tête Thomas Levet et il faisait ciel
bleu ciel bleu ciel bleu et aujourd'hui
plutôt beaucoup de nuag un gros gros
orage cette nuit plie ce matin ça
encourage pas les golfeurs habitués même
s'ils sont passionnés de golf à à venir
plus de 500 personnes mobilisées côté
organisation un Open qui monte en
puissance avant d'accueillir la rider
Cup en 2018 d'ici la rendez-vous le 4
juillet 2013 avec peut-être une victoire
française ce serait la 5e seulement en
plus de 40
ans et le sport continue cet été dans
les Yvelines avec l'ultime étape du Tour
de France qui s'élancera de rambouiller
le 22 juillet pour rallier Paris et les
Champs-Élysées soit 130 km pour cette
dernière étape les coureurs passeront
notamment par Saint-Rémi les chevreuses
alors soyez prêts à les accueillir nous
parlionss du bac en début de cette
émission et si vous avez déjà votre
diplôme en poche les inscriptions pour
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
ont débuté elles se font sur internet
mais aussi vous pouvez aller directement
sur place sauf bien sûr du 27 juillet au
27 août date de fermeture annuelle la la
direction de l'université précise qu'une
inscription rapide permet d'obtenir au
plus vite sa carte étudiant une carte
valable 3 ans et réactivable chaque mois
de septembre politique avec Henry Guenot
qui s'apprête à publier un livre sur son
passage à l'Élysée l'ancienne plume de
Nicolas Sarkozi aujourd'hui élu député
de la 3e circonscription des yvelin
après un parachutage chaotique prépare
actuellement un livre sur ces 5 années
passé au côté de l'ancien chef de l'État
l'ouvrage doit paraître en septembre aux
éditions plomb on imagine bien sûr qu'
devrait y être question de ses rapports
avec l'ancienne équipe gouvernementale
notamment Roseline Bachelot des
relations plutôt glaciales en regeno
n'ayant pas apprécié son dernier ouvrage
sur les coulisses de la campagne qu'il a
simplement jugé vulgaire c'est son
propre terme voici quelques jours
Wilfried savez-vous ce qu'est la Guera
jardinière c'est bien joli comme terme
mais non pas du tout alors en fait c'est
un collectif qui a décidé de se
réapproprier l'espace urbain en y
ajoutant des éléments de verdure une
note de verre au milieu du
béton on a organisé une journée de
réappropriation de l'espace public donc
le but c'était de réaliser différentes
actions des actions comme là on est en
train de le faire de guérill gardening
donc pour revégétaliser la ville donc là
c'est des actions à long terme parce
qu'on va pas se contenter de semer comme
ça et puis de plus revenir ça demande un
peu de suivi la guerria jardinière une
action directe qui consiste à planter et
semer dans l'espace public une pratique
qui nous vient du Japon directement
inspirée par la permaculture la
permaculture ça consiste à faire de
l'agriculture en intervenant le moins
possible sur la nature en laissant la
nature prendre le dessus et ne par
exemple ne pas retourner la terre et
compagnie étant donné que on a de plus
en plus de béton dans la ville et voilà
donc c'est plus sympa d'avoir des fleurs
des plans et c'est le aussi le côté de
de dire qu'on a ce qu'il faut en fait
pour manger à porter de main quoi si on
a des arbres fruitiers objectif
esthétique écologique et donc pratique
ce jour-là le crêpe avait est également
organisé une balade citoyenne pour
promouvoir les transports non polluants
nom de code
[Musique]
Vélorution une initiative suivie d'un
repas partagé de débat et d'intervention
politique du collectif vélodrame contre
l'implantation du Vélodrome à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline il s'agissait
de la deuxème journée de ce type
organisé sur l'agglomération le crêp de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline espère bien
mensualiser l'initiative des septembre
prochain un nouveau rebondissement dans
l'affaire Ikea le siège de l'entreprise
soupçonnée de surveillance illégale de
ses salariés a été perquisitionné en fin
de semaine dernière c'est la seconde
opération de ce type menée à plaisir
dans les ivelines aucune mise en examen
pour l'instant doncun employé l'affaire
avait éclaté en février dernier avec la
publication de documents accablant le
géant suédois c'était dans les pages du
Canard Enchaîné on parle à présent des
vacances d'été Wilfried est-ce que vous
allez porter des lunettes de soleil cet
été vu le soleil qui est en CE je suis
pas sûr peut-être que vous partirez un
petit peu plus loin peut-être dans le
Sud alors on va écouter attentivement
les conseils d'un spécialiste qui vous
dit tout pour bien protéger vos
yeux pas beaucoup de soleil en ce moment
et pourtant il faut penser à protéger
ses yeux des rayons des ultraviolets UVA
et UVB qui peuvent donner un certain
nombre de lésions au niveau de la paroi
oculaire avoir des lésions cela ne fait
pas mal d'où l'importance de la
prévention surtout pour les enfants de
moins de 12 ans et les personnes âgées
qui doivent se protéger la seule
solution mettre des lunettes de soleil
mais pas n'importe lesquelles il faut
systématiquement les acheter chez un
opticien il faut surtout pas acheter des
ver solaires qui sont des vers gadgets
qui sont appelés des ver solaires qui
sont des ver gadgets qu'on peut acheter
dans les prises uniques ou ou sur les
marchés ou sur internet faut savoir que
ça ça ne protège en rien c'est des veres
qui sont simplement teintés donc qui
vont jouer sur l'éblouissement mais ça
n'arrête en rien les ultraviolets et
quand vous vous trouverez chez ce
professionnel attention à bien choisir
vos ver Solair il faut qu'il soit
polarisé il faut savoir que quand vous
avez une lumière qui arrive sur une
surface plane cette lumière va provoquer
va se polariser et ça va provoquer une
une réverbération et des reflets qui
pour le pour l'individu donne un
éblouissement une baisse de baisse de
vision une baisse d'acuité visuelle et
le fait que le verre soit polarisé ça
permet à l'œil de ne recevoir que la
lumière qui apporte une information
visuelle c'est que le verre polarisé
fonctionne un peu comme un storvénicien
SI vous voulez il faut également bien
choisir son indice dit indice de
réfraction qui va de 0 à 4 disons que 0
1 et 2 c'est des veres qui sont peu
teintés et qui qui servent
essentiellement pour le soleil qu'on
peut avoir sur la région parisienne
l'indice 3 c'est l'indice qui est le
plus fréquemment utilisé et qu'on
utilise à la plage ou ou dans des des
pays où il y a beaucoup de soleil et
l'indice 4 c'est vraiment ce qu'on
utilise alors à la neige ou dans les
vers ou alors si vous allez vraiment
dans des des pays où il y a énormément
énormément de soil
enfin la teinte des veres a également
son importance choisir une teinte grise
si vous êtes hyper métrope et une teinte
brune si vous êtes miop et on garde ses
lunettes de soleil pour fêter l'été et
l'été et le soleil à Mani les AM qui
mène pour la troisème fois son opération
remet tong une manière de profiter des
vacances et de s'amuser en famille tout
en restant chez
soi un air de premier jour de vacances à
manilé à mot avec l'opération RTT ou
plutôt remetton 3e édition du genre des
animations quel pe g par la pluie
heureusement il y avait les staminet
pour accueillir ce samedi le public avec
différents jeux dont un parcours de
bille on le monde de la mer le monde de
la jungle la montagne de
suite univers différent à chaque fois
d'aur qu' jou de moins en moins au
parceils ont un pe peu de mal quand même
plus de 20 associations locales ont
particip à cette opération plastique
coner babot mini
[Musique]
Bard qui éta faite par toutes les
associations et les services municipaux
de la ville en une seule opération qui
s'est appelé REM pour permettre au Manis
de se sentir en vacances un petit peu
avant les vacances c'est
intergénérationnel c'est des tout petits
des plus plus petit qu'on mène les
opérations dès la naissance et à partir
de 9 mois jusqu'au plus ancien qui
partage tout ce qu'on mène et tout ce
qu'on a envie de faire et ce n'est pas
fiette c'est encore mardi soir avec
concert cinéma en plein air vendredi
prochain l'opération se termine par un
grand bal suivi d'un feu d'artifice
cette fête de l'été coïncidait aussi
avec la fin des travaux de
réhabilitation des espaces publics et
des parkings du quartier du Buisson une
exposition de photos rappelait l'avant
et l'après et le bouquet final de cette
fête à maniléamo c'est donc ce feu
d'artifice et bal populaire le vendredi
13 Juillet et demain n'oubliez pas
initiation au kickboxing et cinéma de
plein air merci Alice pour ce point sur
l'actualité locale on vous retrouve
demain vers 18h 15 pour un nouveau
journal en direct le 78 est presque
terminé pour ce soir auparavant un petit
micro trottoir quelles sont vos
activités pendant l'été vos réponses au
micro de Guillaume camp et de Patrick
Jacques de dixmud les vacances ça déjà
passé oui je reviens de de Crète donc
les vacances sont terminées aller voir
ma sœur qui va bientôt accoucher dans
l'avyon ah d'accord voilà alors c'est
dans combien de temps les vacances et
l'accouchement alors l'accouchement
c'est ce mois-ci et les vacances c'est
dans un mois projet de vacances le
Pays-Basque j'emmène mes petits enfants
sur la Côte d'Azur et je m'occupe d'eux
pendant toutes les vacances voilà au
soleil on va chercher le soleil alors
pour les vacances je reste chez moi
parce queil y a beaucoup moins de monde
dans les ivelines à mag à on est
tranquille ça va être sensationn on va
pouir profiter pour beaucoup de voiture
il y a beaucoup d'activités sur la
commune donc tout va bien à part le
temps mais peut-être que TVF va nous une
combine pour le temps non non vous avvez
pas une petite combine pour le soleil
non on n'ura pas de conseil
malheureusement à donner pour le retour
du soleil nous aussi on l'attend avant
de conclure cette édition une petite
rectification jeudi au cours du 78 nous
évoquions le logement étudiant au cours
de la discussion notre invité a évoqué
la fondation fondinterrain en tant que
partenaire de l'Université de Versailles
5tin il fallait en réalité comprendre la
Fondation UVSQ fondation université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin et d'ailleurs
demain nous parlerons à nouveau du
longement étudiant à l'occasion du forum
qui s'est déroulé ce weekend à Guill
encour rendez-vous à 18h pour plus de
détails prochain rendez-vous
d'information le tout image l'actu de la
rédaction c'est à 20h30 et à 22h le 78
revient demain mardi invité le club de
triathlon de Saint-Quentin qui prépare
les Joos de Londres excellente
[Musique]
soirée